is a new 300 homepod worth buying over
the 200 Echo Studio or the 100 Nest
audio well today we're gonna listen to
three separate tracks so that you guys
can hear all of the differences not only
that but I'm also going to use an
equalizer app to show you guys the
difference in frequency response so you
guys can see the differences as well now
I also made a comparison between the
original homepod and a stereo pair of
homepod mini so if you guys want to see
that check out the link in the
description or after this video now this
first test is gonna be a loudness
comparison because sometimes you just
need to turn it all the way up
[Music]
bring me back
well there's no doubt that the echo
studio is definitely the loudest it hit
92 decibels three feet away compared to
91 on the nest and 86 on the homepod so
the homepod's a quietest but with a nest
if you Max it out most of that volumes
from the high frequencies the mids and
the bass don't kick up as much so right
now I'm gonna lower down the volumes
make them all equal and we can compare
the sound quality
[Music]
bring me back
so where we started
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section I will just say that
the nest cannot compete now Google used
to make the Google Max that thing was a
beast and it had great bass but this one
just really lacks both in base and the
highs you hear some bass but it doesn't
dig low like these two do now the echo
Studio the base is Bump and you guys can
actually see the subwoofer moving it is
really big and the base is louder here
and you're gonna EQ that of course but
the homepod actually digs deeper it gets
lower and overall even though these are
similar in sound quality the homepod is
the best now let's go ahead and change
to a more classical track
foreign
[Music]
The Nest is painful to listen to after
you heard of these ones and the worst
thing is it's directional so you guys
are hearing the best of it through our
850 microphone setup and when you move
to the side it gets even worse now
comparing these two I do like the mids
better in the Echo Studio but overall
the homepod once again sounds the best
you have a little bit better Clarity the
bass digs deeper even though it's not as
loud I prefer the homepod even though I
don't even own it I own this Echo studio
and now let's switch to a rock track
that has so many different instruments
it is much tougher
is
[Music]
[Applause]
and for this one the homepod wins once
again now the nest sounds worse than
Apple's homepod mini it is crazy worse
in every way other than it can get a
little bit louder but it sounds terrible
at it so please don't buy this get a
homepod mini instead or one of the
smaller 100 Echoes this thing is sad now
the echo Studio still sounds good it has
a little bit more bass in my opinion but
overall you get more clarity and more
separation between instruments with the
homepod so it is the winner now as for
our analysis I set the volumes to be the
same here we have the homepod 2 the echo
studio and the nest here's all of them
at one so you guys can freeze frame this
if you guys want to look at it in detail
and this is the homepod 2 compared to
the echo so the echo actually has more
low end base starting from around 30
Hertz it starts to kick up all the way
up to about 60 or so right here where
the homepod starts to take over now keep
in mind this is set to the same volume
so when you're playing them 70 to 80
percent the homepod definitely has more
bass right up until 200 Hertz Apple
really likes to push that from 400 up to
a thousand they are fairly similar here
and then the echo drops off all the way
over here you see the home pod pushes
that up so those tweeters really start
to stand out and the homepod has us dip
and then kicks back up higher so the
echo is a lot more flat a lot more true
to life and then has more sub bass now
comparing the homepod to the nest The
Nest has no base and even when it kicks
up it is so low here it stays a lot more
flat and then doesn't have the highs and
the Sparkle from the tweeters where the
homepod has five of them instead of one
now as far as the base output at 40
Hertz here the echo has way more if you
turn the speaker up 87 decibels compared
to 72. switching over to 60 hertz the
homepod kicks up here but the echo can
still output way more bass relative to
the homepod if we're maxing out the
volume comparing the echo to the nest
the echo at 40 Hertz gets close to the
nest out of 100 Hertz in terms of output
it is insane and the echo Studio at 60
hertz actually puts out more bass than
the nest at 100 Hertz we have 91
decibels compared to 94. so the nest is
really an embarrassment as far as base
output it's not even close to the other
ones so with that said will I switch
from the echo Studio to the homepod no
for a couple of reasons one I like my
music loud and this thing gets actually
louder than two homepods put together
which cost you 600 bucks this is still
slightly louder and the second thing is
Apple really limits how you can connect
to this you can't do Bluetooth like you
can with Echo Studio there is no
physical input as well and you can't do
Spotify connect so you can AirPlay to it
with that your EQ settings go out the
window and if you're connecting from
your laptop or your phone which is nice
if you're a Mac User iOS user well if
you play anything else on your phone it
overrides it where here you can cast to
it do anything else you want on your
phone or whatever in it plays just fine
now both of these can also pair to other
ones you can actually pair four of these
together you could do a surround sound
if you have one of the Amazon devices
which I don't have because I don't like
them and as far as smart capabilities of
course these are smart speakers the
Alexa ecosystem shouldn't have said that
word it is by far the most capable it
has the most compatibility with
different devices uh the nest is in
second place a little bit behind but the
homepod is by far the most limiting and
as far as the smart assistant smartness
it is the most dumb as well but if you
like great sound quality and you have
the money and you're okay with the
limitations it is a fantastic sounding
speaker for the price and if you don't
need maximum volume I think it is worth
spending the extra money over this Echo
now with that said check out the
comparison between two homepod minis
which come in at 200 bucks just like the
studio and the original one right over
there click above to subscribe to see
more videos and I'll see you in the next
one
foreign